check this out DJI has just launched
their new DJI Mini 4 Pro drone and I am
so excited about this because the mini
lineup of their drones is some of my
favorites now because they are so small
they obviously don't have all of the
features that most of the more expensive
and pro drones have but with every
upgrade this little guy is getting
better and better it really is the
perfect beginner drone but also even if
you're a pro the fact that this is so
small portable and compact with
surprisingly Incredible video footage
this might be the Drone that you always
have with you you know just in case you
need to get a shot let's unbox it and
check it out
[Music]
you get a little travel ERS case you
have your controller drone batteries and
of course extra propellers and here's
the little drone look how cute it's so
small I always call this the prop belt
but I love that they have this new
design to keep your propellers in place
when you're traveling with this this
makes it easy to pack and keeps your
propellers safe so here's our battery
it's super small this kit comes with
three batteries and a charger and here's
the controller the joysticks are in the
back just pop them out and on when it's
time to fly we also have some ND filters
we have a 16 64 and 256 and these are
great for super bright days when you're
flying we also have a wide angle lens
I'm excited to try this out I've
actually never used one of these before
on a drone they work just like the ND
filters you just pop off the lens and
pop on the wide angle lens so now this
is all unboxed let's pack up and go fly
[Music]
the best part about these mini drones is
strategically it weighs under 249 grams
so that you won't need to register it
with the FAA for recreational operation
we fly here it's so unreal all the
things that this little drone can do
while still being so light now as for
video it can shoot 4K video 4K 60 4K 100
frames a second night mode and d-log M
now I love that for vertical content
creators you can shoot true vertical
videos with this it's so easy you just
flip it into the vertical mode and the
camera rotates so you can get the
perfect vertical shot I don't take
photos that often with drones but I'm
trying to get better but this has a one
and one-third inch sensor that allows
you to shoot 48 megapixel photos at 24
millimeters let's get a piano we can do
sphere 180 wide angle or even one of the
verticals I'm going to do a little 180
here
sick
[Music]
360 photo is pretty cool it'll take a
bunch of photos and create this 360
image automatically so when you go into
your editor you can scroll around and
reframe it to whatever shot you like
[Music]
now if you want to get a wider angle
point of view you can use this new wide
angle lens to really change up the look
all right let's pop on this wide angle
I'm so excited to try this here we go
oh my gosh it's so much wider like this
is so close to me I got to put it in
sport mode so I can get closer oh Jesus
oh gosh
it's so wide angle this is so great
[Music]
wow it gives you like this whole New
Perspective I've actually never used a
wide angle lens like this like it looks
like I'm so much further away than I am
oh the sun setting
I love this for shooting vertical videos
because it'll give you a much wider
field of view it has new omnidirectional
obstacle sensing and a new way to use
active track 360. they have a trace
wheel where you can use your finger to
show how you want to move around your
subject this also allows for you to
navigate around obstacles it even has
the ability to Auto recognize and replan
the tracking route after losing the
subject the transmission system also has
an upgrade to ocusync 4.0 so let's check
out some of the active tracking features
basically I have to just
draw a little box around myself we have
point of Interest Spotlight and active
track so this is Spotlight it'll stay
put but it'll still follow me wherever I
go
but the Drone stays still now with
active track this is where it gets fun
so here's our little Trace wheel and
this is super cool because this allows
us to actually trace a path around us
and we can go around obstacles
there it goes it's going around
[Music]
and it's great because it does have the
obstacle sensing that it's able to
determine if there's
something nearby now for battery life
much like all drones flight time will
vary but you can get up to 45 minutes of
flight time which is pretty impressive
for such a small drone
[Music]
I love these quick shots they're so fun
we can do drones rocket Circle Helix
Boomerang I've demoed all of these in
previous videos but this droney and the
rocket are my favorite shots to get
foreign
[Music]
this is so fun this is definitely my new
favorite go-to drone that will never
leave my travel bag I do obviously have
my Pro drones but this is something that
even if I don't plan on taking a drone
it's small enough that I can fit
anywhere
oh
[Music]
I will say something that I was
impressed with is how small this drone
was its ability to capture these low
light videos they actually look pretty
impressive when you put it into night
mode and don't forget this also does
have a zoom so here is the 1X the 2X and
the 3x look at our little
not ready to land yet
do I look like I'm I'm being abducted by
aliens
foreign